hi hello hey
how's it going i need i need to find a
knife please hold hold on i gotta get a
knife
hey guys
we gotta make this real quick
i just got a package in the mail my
camera is all crooked but
finally received something in the mail
that i have been waiting for it is the
new apple watch it's the steel version
every time i get a knife
i realize i don't need it because
there's
this tab probably gonna miss my flight
because i need to go to the airport
like 20 minutes ago
open open open open open open up and
open looking good
i don't recall
the sport version
coming with a charger like this
this is a really awesome box i hope that
i can gut it and oh my god i can't i can
put stuff in it
wow this looks really manly
i am not a man
oh but my goodness
look at that
how do i take these
loops out though so my plan was if i was
real into this one i was gonna sell this
one to my sister jenna because she was
thinking of getting one so i was like
hold up girl wait a minute this is so
heavy
this feels like a freaking ton of bricks
in my hand compared to the aluminum
wow it is so
big
it's freaking real big at the time i was
thinking yo this 38 real tiny well now
i'm thinking holy crap 42 what do i do
what do i do what do i do i think i'm
just gonna return it and save my money
i think that's
that's what i that's what i think i'm
gonna do some of you guys might have
heard the really sad news that my hard
drive crashed on my imac so
i lost everything why didn't you back up
your files justine i don't know because
i'm an idiot this was real big
i think you might be too big
and don't even say that's what she said
because guess what i'm a she and i said
it so shut your mouth now i'm gonna take
this to the airport and see if jenna is
gonna buy it off of me
jenna i accept paypal don't you worry
girl don't worry i've got a square
reader if you just want to give me your
credit card i am a child in the candy
store the candy store of apple of love
it is really freaking heavy i'm gonna
have to wear an equal amount of
bracelets on this arm because i'm gonna
be so jacked up everyone's gonna be like
yo you're doing roids or you've been
hitting the gym are you becoming a
bodybuilder no i'm just wearing my apple
watch that is 50 pounds
but you look great
smells good because i'm not gonna have
time to figure out how to change these
loops let me look at the directions am i
packed do i have things are my clothes
in order am i in order i am not well oh
oh you're so thoughtful
it's a nice little
satchel to put your links in
oh a nice little rag to clean it thank
you how considerate
press the button on the inside of the
bracelet to pull apart and remove a link
pull apart push a button this is easy
look at this guys
there's these little buttons
here
you push them
i hope this is easy it looks easy on the
directions
yo i ain't got time for this i'm gonna
miss my plane wait push the button push
push the button
am i pushing the button
where's the button
snore
that's it i did it holy crap okay
trouble
the bus that i'm on is the struggle buzz
okay took off two that's it that's
pretty easy hey man oh god
what the hell just happened jenna just
text me why are you leaving the airport
oh now
i can't wait to get her thoughts so i'll
see you in a second at the airport with
jenna all right guys meet the airport
guess what jenna
are you going to paypal me are you going
to paypal me
you just had a fake on me you should
just please shut up there you go take it
off see let's how we'll see what you
think
i'm
i like i actually i like this
i love the milk when you first said
something about the white
he's not into that
wait a minute we're gonna have to reset
it up because it's set up right now for
did you bring two chargers
it's just on fleek you know
yeah i'm kind of into this and if when i
first put it on it was really heavy i
feel so used to this one it's so light
and awesome
so yeah this is nice i think i think
it's gonna happen yeah is this a man
band
um
that's what i was thinking it's a little
manly
but you know what
okay
look how grimy
good afternoon
all right
okay well i'm trying to but
nothing's happening
oh shoot is this one trying to pair
oh no all right guys how do you use it
well we got to set this up to your phone
so we'll do that later anyway i'll see
you later i guess the uh the official
exchange has been exchanged
okay bye
how many hot dogs can i cook in this
do whatever you want to do this would
have been so much easier with a grill
all right how do you work this thing